thanks to Logitech G for sponsoring
today's video this podcast and every
other podcast I make is brought to you
by our supporters on patreon they got
this episode about a week early we're
able to submit questions and have a
totally adree version of the show so if
you want to check it out and support
these very independent podcast that I
make the link is in the description it's
also the only place you can get an audio
version of this show for the record now
here's the show hello everyone welcome
to another episode of voice acting 101
I'm Alana and I here with who are you
and what are you doing here
told you it' be
aggressive I am Jennifer English and I
play shadow heart in balers gate three
which is apparently quite a big deal at
the moment allegedly that's why I'm here
I think oh
butut um yeah likewise I mean I think
I'm here because I play um Deborah wild
and I play LEL in Boulders Gate 3 also a
pretty big
deal int she follows me around wherever
I go I can't get rid of pretty much
pretty much that's it that's how it goes
us and us and our baby
imp uh I'm sure you've been asked this
question like a million times but it's
the most burning question that everyone
I know has about this game
how did you record that much dialogue
and still keep track of character arcs I
don't understand it's so many
permutations and so many options like
literally how do you keep track of a
character good question we don't we
don't that's the answer are paid for
that's what the directors are for that's
what the directors for I go in with a
blank mind like a little fairy and I
just go give me the context give me the
words and then I just I say the lines um
that's pretty much my process I can
confirm that is exactly her
process that is my that's my I don't
have space in this brain to hold um all
of the character charts also because we
didn't know um we didn't know the
character charts when we began so we
were kind of doing it as yeah we didn't
really I mean I think they had like
rough character Arts didn't they Jen but
we didn't have um the full story let's
put it that way so we were kind of just
doing it as we went along and I think
that made life a lot easier because yeah
you don't have to worry about everything
I think if I'd G been given all that
information at the beginning I would
have been very overwhelmed yeah
completely we would have been yeah it
would have been just way too much but
yeah like I would just go in and every
new scene just asks asks shitloads of
questions am I oh yeah go ahead um does
that [__] how does that affect your
performance it's a very unconventional
way of acting I imagine that you like
don't really know where your character
is in any given time like is that did
you just have to adapt you you just you
don't have a choice so you just kind of
have to do it or was it something that
you still tried to Wrangle somehow I
think um you know how like taxi drivers
if you study a tax not expecting your
answer just with this NE wait wait wait
you know taxi drivers have all the old
school taxi drivers before Uber I
remember watching or reading something
and they had they like the part of their
brain that remembers maps and roots and
things is huge sure and like I don't
think they they were like that and
that's why they became taxi drivers I
think you like learn and then your brain
gets bigger I don't know I'm not a
neuroscientist but my bu you should be I
should be God Dr
Jen H but I think like the
imagination section of our brain is now
pretty [__] massive like like at the
beginning it was hard and luckily they
re-recorded quite a lot of that so good
but um yeah the at the beginning like
having to go right hang on wait okay
where are we who am I talking to where
in the story are we because obviously
we'd flip-flop about there was no linear
narrative going on as far as the
recording sessions are concerned and
that I like and then towards the end
you're like okay I know exact okay
underd duck brilliant who am I talking
to brilliant and I can just picture it
and I can picture who I'm talking to so
your brain is just one giant like balls
gate through library at this point Absol
yeah that's cool at the beginning it was
just a jumble of like words and phrases
I think and like random things and now
at the end I'm like oh that's what's
happening and that's how they're all
pieced together but the beginning people
were just saying like random stuff to me
and I was like okay I don't know what
this means but I'm gonna go with it what
is this yeah I just feel like surely for
the both of you that must not that must
be very different to every other acting
experience you've ever had right like it
seems like you just kind of thrown in
there and they're like figure it out but
there's there's so much to figure out
like it just seems so daunting to me
that I'm so impressed this game came
together in so many ways but the fact
that there's so many voice lines and so
many characters they have so many
different interactions I can't even
imagine how messy that was for well
especially towards the end because we'd
have like from for shadow heart anyway
like there were two really distinct
parts and sometimes it would go
uh One path this like this line other
path the other line when of course those
were completely
D yeah and and you wouldn't do like one
scene all as one one scene all as the
other we were literally flip-flopping so
like to to flip between emotional states
is well and not just the imagination bit
the emotional state bit and having to go
like yeah I don't want to give too many
spoilers away but like very very
different and so I had to do that in a
game one once uh in one game that I I'm
not like an actor but occasionally will
voice act a little bit in games which is
part of what sparked me to do this
podcast with people who are actually
talented and I had to do that once where
I was swapping between dramatic emotions
based on dialogue choices and I left
that which might have been like a 2-hour
session exhausted yeah because I was
having to constantly shift between the
two of them and then you're having to do
that for like a several hundred hour
game yeah is there anything that can
prepare you for sessions like that like
literally having to drag different
emotions out of yourself to make sure
that you can sell what's going on I
would always make sure I had [__] tons
asleep what about you death yeah yeah
yeah yeah and just I mean I don't know I
think we talked about this in in another
interview um Jen but like how at the
beginning I I was very prepared and like
very sort of picity and then as time
went on I I'd sort of dropped that
preparation a little bit and just go in
fresh um because then I'm not so like
bogged down with all of it yeah yeah and
then I can sort of and then I'm reading
the script and it's fresh and I can be
like okay then it's then it's easier for
me to sort of flip from one to the other
rather than oh [__] now I'm now I'm
reading the script now I know that
tomorrow I've got to do this and now
it's like oh so I prefer I much prefer
going in almost like a blank slate and
just sort of doing it like that so how
long did you actually record
for four years four years that's so nuts
it's been four years four long years
pmic like life changes wild crazy yeah
you're different people now like four
years is enough for dramatic Life
Changes yeah yeah yeah a lot yeah so did
you if I imagine you started during the
pandemic or just before just
before knew there would be a pandemic
wow life is different
now did you ever get to record stuff in
the same
room entirely no unfortunately not it
would have loved that so much we really
wanted to we really wanted to and we
asked for it but I think it there's just
so many actors in this project and uh
scheduling would have been a nightmare
and also some of the scenes involv like
multiple people so it would have just
been really hard to to do that but it
would have been nice yeah there's one
scene in particular between me and and
Deb me and shadowart and lelle uh and I
wonder if it's the same one you're think
that you might guess it is but I like
the
spoilers oh yeah knife scene I was being
really careful about I don't think
that's a spoiler I think you're okay
that's not a spoiler that's not a spoil
game has knives in it everybody it does
have knives violence yeah there's a
particular thing that might or might not
involve a knife that um yeah I would
really like to have done with Dev yeah
yeah that would have been good in
instead we had to use a
pillow I to straddle a p pillow you
should do like a re recording of all
your favorite scenes I'm sure they'd be
done to do that do a little Charity
Drive for you I really want to I really
want to do outakes I really want to find
some bloopers but um I guess we've got
to ask like if anybody stored those I
don't know but that would be hilarious
because there's a lot there's a lot like
they generally do store them but I think
going through them would be a lot of
work take really long four years of four
years worth of
material yeah um so to backtrack a whole
bunch uh where did you both start in
your careers like what what how did you
start out as as actors and what led you
to the point where you got to Boulders
gate
three oh well let's go back way back
um well I well this year marks my 10th
year of being an actor hooray made it
yay um that actually is a good
accomplishment it's a it's an industry
full of rejection and constantly struggl
Ling and it's not easy so 10 years is
amazing congratulations it is and and a
lot of uh when I was I went to drama
school and a lot of my teachers and a
lot of people would say like so you've
got to be in it for 10 years until you
see like some sort of success and I'd be
like no way I'm gonna go out and like
win an Oscar um obviously that did not
happen uh yet yet yet exactly but but
it's really true that it's been sort of
the culmination of of many years of work
and um I did other stuff before I I went
to University and I did English
literature then I did a masters in
fashion journalism and then I was like
right I really need to pursue my actual
passion which is acting because if I
don't I'm going to regret it and fashion
journalism really interesting Masters
though what does that entail yes well as
an aside sorry I don't what is what is
what does that
mean learning how to write about fashion
but honestly I didn't really learn a lot
like as a lot
like yeah yeah I went to the in College
of fashion and did like a MERS in that
wow so like a very you know it's like a
very famous school where like but but I
think most people go there to be like
designers and most people go there
they're like very Arty and and they can
draw and they can do that I can't I
can't draw for [__] um but I can write
so I was like I should just you know I
should do that and I liked fashion and
it was the time when um when fashion
blogs were explo were exploding you know
before social media was a thing you know
everyone was doing their blogs and I was
really obsessed with them so I was like
yeah maybe that's my path in life yeah
it was not my path that going for
you no it it was not for me um I didn't
like it I did a couple of internships
and I was there to like learn how to be
a fashion journalist journalist and
essentially I just ended up folding
clothes in a clothed cupboard um for
like the duration of those internships
and I was not happy about that and I
realized I didn't love it enough to to
continue yeah um so yeah then acting
went to drama school um and then sort of
six years into my career I thought about
voiceovers because a lot of people had
told me that I had a nice voice um even
while I was doing fashion journalism
which was very strange they were like oh
you got a really nice voice blah blah
and I was like okay well I've heard
voiceovers are like sort of lucrative
and that could be like a nice side
hustle joke joke I mean look at this
like look look at us now hilarious and
um
and boulders Gate 3 was my first uh
thing that I booked uh through my
voiceover agent and I hadn't I didn't
have a clue what I was auditioning for I
really didn't have a clue about it at
all and I guess it just turned out
really serendipitously because um I
think had I known the scope of the game
I would have been uh much more
intimidated and probably done a really
[__] audition but I didn't really know
and it happens a lot I feel like it's
really common people like don't know
especially if like you I don't know how
much you know about video games in
general but if you aren't like super
involved in the games industry and then
and then it blows up and you're like
what's this huge thing these people care
about yeah like I feel like it happens a
lot it's fun I had no clue I had no clue
and honestly when I when I got my
voiceover agent I was like oh voiceovers
a commercials yeah and and voice that's
what voice I had no uh even I didn't my
mind didn't even go to video games at
all so now that video game is such a big
part of my life it's I find it quite
hilarious you've started with a very
good one and welcome you're one of us
now thank you thank you how about you
Jennifer what was your start as an
actress started uh so went to drama
school as well and and started like
almost exclusively with theater and did
that for many many years and would still
do it but um the money [__] so maybe not
I don't know pic probably also made that
sort of tough I would think yeah oh yeah
it was really like yeah and um you know
still doing like all all sorts and still
up for doing like that's the thing with
and like as you probably know in the UK
there's no separation between voice
actors and actors like I think nearly
everyone in the game does
everything it's it's very like every
yeah everyone everyone does TV everyone
does film everyone does theater it's
just and I quite like that there's a
real freedom and you don't you don't get
as pigeonholed I think as especially in
the states and things where it feels
like every the people in video games are
video game actors like is that what it's
like yeah it's really strange um people
very rarely
cross uh disciplines and if they do
people are surprised they're like oh
they can act we like well yeah they've
been doing that the whole time it's it
is very strange I don't really know
what's caused that definitely a thing
yeah um you both mentioned going to
school and I feel like every time that
spoken to uh anyone from England or the
UK in General on this show they always
have been to drama school is that like a
like a a big cultural thing in the UK
where you feel like there's a big push
for it because a lot of the actors here
like in the US and even in Australia
didn't study drama they just like kind
of showed up and started somehow someday
yeah yeah no it's very much the kind of
I I mean saying that the the like having
directed on this game as well um like it
it doesn't make a different too much of
a difference whether like and some of
the best actors that I've worked with
haven't gone to drama school it's not a
necessity here but it is it is I would
say definitely part of the culture and
definitely expected is it a pressure
thing don't know I mean the training is
very
good yeah I think it's more the fact
that you sort of it's very hard to get
your foot in if you don't go because you
can't join Spotlight obviously without
having um obviously without having
credit or going to drama school so if
you don't have a credit then and then
you can't get an agent without having so
it's all like that makes sense you know
it's all mixed it's all sort of linked
and then I I do feel like some agents
most agents actually um won't take you
unless you've been to like a drama
school not only any drama school but
like a certain drama school I do think
that um things are changing now and
people are getting their opportunities
more themselves and people using social
media and people aren't going that route
which I think is great because honestly
um I don't think that I learn a lot at
drama school it is time to talk about
the absolutely beautiful Astro 830
wireless gaming headset so first things
first
obviously this is a beautiful headset in
my opinion it's super stylish which I
feel like a lot of gaming headsets
aren't I just feel like it's especially
Sleek which is very good considering
it's a headset that's more compatible
with your lifestyle not just gaming the
a30 wireless lets you play anything
anywhere it's compatible with PC
portable gaming device devices Xbox
series s and X PlayStation 5 Nintendo
switch so you can just jump between
devices with the same one headset and
you can do so simultaneously the
Logitech G mobile app allows you to mix
and balance audio from multiple
different sources at once I did not find
a single scenario in which I needed
audio that it was not the perfect fit
for it also has 27 hours of battery life
and wonderful audio quality with 40 mm
drivers also of course Very importantly
it has this beautiful memory foam
padding here on the earpads and earband
of course you don't have to Go Wireless
while there is the light speeed Wireless
2.4 GHz connection as a lovely option it
is also Bluetooth compatible and can be
connected by a 3.5 mm Ox cable worth
mentioning for those of you who don't
have Standalone microphones like I do it
does also have a built-in microphone and
an attachable boom mic which is very
cool and it comes with this lovely
travel case I don't know what else to
tell you what else could you possibly
want it is about time I had an upgrade
thank you Astro St across the board I do
feel like there are certain people who
aren't geared to that kind of learning
and it sucks that we like gatekeep a lot
of careers because there are certain
like especially creative ones because
people like aren't you know aren't uh
compatible with the education system and
that's like a huge thing it's it's a big
Financial commitment and oh God yeah
like like I I would have loved to have
gone to University and done drama school
but there was there was absolutely no
way way on Earth I could have afforded
that just there's just like it wouldn't
have happened um but I feel like like
drama schools now like it is such a big
Financial commitment because especially
so expensive London and you just can't
affordably live as a student in London
unless you are of privilege and then you
look at why especially in the UK why so
many of the successful actors are really
Posh and really rich absolutely
absolutely it also creates kind of actor
because they're all coming from the same
background which is very
boring
unfortunately changing slowly but I
think we we've got a long way to go and
as I say like I've worked with lots of
untrained actors and or like people that
have come from a a not drama school
background shall we say and I think as
Dev says like like I learned loads at
drama school but I think nine 90% of it
I've learned on the job like you just on
the job always 100% yeah 100% so much
yeah you learn quicker you're there
you're you're doing it practically drama
school is very uh Theory bed I mean you
know I don't know about you Jen but we
spent like a whole term on Shakespeare
I've never auditioned for Shakespeare
ever and I don't think I ever will I
don't think I ever will I think the
system here is so God we've got very
we've got very political but it's very
like it it's the opportunities
especially for theater here are very
gate kept
and certain people audition for things
and especially Shakespeare I mean that's
like Elite of the elite kind of thing
like why am I spending a term doing
[__] McBeth and like ringing my hands
and I don't know like
speaking English I love oh no but it's
not that specific that's everyone at
drama school like no that's what I mean
it's like it's such a specific thing to
learn that isn't actually helpful to
most other things again I love
Shakespeare but it's like like how is
that even really transferable it's not
and you're not taught how to like well
certainly wer at my drama school we
weren't taught how to act for TV and T
TV and film no way you know how much
time we spent on voice over like one
session I think one or two sessions on
voice and that's now like our biggest
you know a big part of our career is is
it's good that things are changing yeah
I mean the system the education system
probably need to catch up there also I
want to apologize if you can hear
background noise I'm trying to mute it
out if I can both to the two of you and
everyone
listen excellent Zoom killing it um so
for for anyone who's looking to get into
acting obviously for all the criticisms
that iwe have of the education system I
do highly encourage people go to school
learning is good um but do you have any
advice like outside of just that for
anyone who would like to become an actor
and do what the two of you
do um
I I would say only do it if you need to
do it and and because it is a really
really really tough career um I say do
it if you literally cannot think to do
anything else if you can do that it's
like much easier but I'd say practice
practice practice practice record
yourself listen back to yourself watch
other actors watch like you know whe
whatever medium it is you want to do and
like if it's video games then then watch
the best video game performances and and
study them and learn from them um watch
really brilliant TV and film watch
theater if that's what you want to do
and just learn and learn and learn and
and yeah and practice as much as
possible and and do as many courses as
you can and workshops you don't need to
go to drama school if you can afford it
and you do want to do it bloody well go
great um but if you can't there are so
many other roots and look at look at
your favorite actors and how they did it
and if they are postion rich maybe
ignore that or have a really famous
learning maybe ignore those too just be
POS and Rich it's that easy all that or
just be Posh and Rich figure it out
you'll be fine um but yeah like look at
The Underdogs and how they did it and
and just yeah think outside the box as
well as well you know you don't have to
go the traditional route I mean this
isn't the traditional route as far as
the UK acting scene is concerned like
video games is still a massively new and
exciting thing and I feel like the
industry is still the industry but you
know the creative industry is still
really learning about it and
appreciating it in a different way and I
feel like we at the moment are going
like hi like this is this this acting is
as good as TV and film take this ser and
the writing is good is as good as TV and
film like you don't have to go the
boring route whatever that boring route
is you can do something exciting that
excites you I've kind of lost steam now
Dev you take
it well no I I second all of that and I
I just think that um to to add to what
Jen said uh you have to accept that a
lot of this industry is luck and you
know we can't be around the bush like I
I think that the whole cast is
incredible in Boulders Gate 3 and we've
all done amazing work but but even
getting that audition is is luck you
know we were at the right place at the
right time and yes we nailed the
auditions and we got cast but but you
know had I been with a different agent
maybe or had I been had I something
might have happened and I might never
have got to that opportunity so the
point of the story is and that's it's
still hard for me to really accept that
a lot of this industry is luck and if
you can't accept that then it's not
really for you um a l of and the second
thing I want to say which a lot of any
success a lot of any success is luck and
I would never trust anyone who says that
their success did not come at the
expense of luck it doesn't mean you
didn't work C doesn't mean you didn't
you didn't work your ass off but luck is
still a factor in a million ways and
anyone who's like I did it all by myself
and no luck is kidding no no no no no no
no things have to sort of collide in a
certain way and I think they definitely
did for this game um for us all and then
uh and then yeah just again sort of
seconding what Jen said about uh you
know I always think voice acting is
acting so we we shouldn't really
separate them so if you if you want to
be a voice actor you should train as an
actor and you should do all the things
that you would do if you were
considering being a normal actor it's
the same so whatever you need to do be
that drama school not drama school
courses workshops whatever but you're
not going to get performance unless you
really um unless you really know the
craft and you know the character it's
not just putting on a silly voice and I
think for a long time that's what video
game acting was but now people are like
oh wait these are actually like real
characters with real like flaws and
problems and you know all of that good
stuff that makes a great character um so
we have to approach it from that sense
not just like oh I'm going to change my
voice and Pitch it lower and that's the
character it's not that at all um yeah
so many people think it's that as fun as
I know they do no it's a lot harder than
I know they do and that and that's why
people with Boulders Gate 3 are like oh
my God this is actually like cinema this
is like watching a movie um yeah it is
yeah we've worked [__] hard for it of
course yeah um so Jennifer I realized we
didn't really fully get your background
uh how did you get involved with balers
Gate 3 because I know you mentioned that
you directed parts of it too yeah yeah
that that came after um I started
working on it as Shadow heart um but the
yeah I how did I get on it I yes I
didn't I've done loads of theater kind
of done all sorts and then um TR like I
dabbled in doing voice over and was like
I was doing audio books and hated it
because I have ADHD and it's just too
hard they're terrible because they take
a really long time in Peri they take a
really long time I don't mind the other
side of it I've directed them great
that's fine and just being paid to read
a book all good but the the
concentration levels that you need to to
read an Audi book no thanks don't like
it um so tried that and then but because
I had and I think I did did a good job
at them but because I had the reals and
stuff I got a voice agent and then then
auditioned for dos 2 and the rest is
history because it was the same Josh the
same director um at stop who um Larry
and outsourced to for the dialogue
recording and so yeah so played a bunch
of characters in that and then did loads
more video games and then this audition
came along and it was one of those
auditions where I was like I know Josh
I'm I'm not gonna try that hard and I
did like honestly I did such minimal
effort I mean I've watched it back and
is a good audition but like I did not
try at all and so many auditions those
are the best those are the best like
honestly I'll get a self tape for like
we've got like a soap here like called
doctors which is like where a lot of
actors like cut their teeth on and
whatever and it's like a day day like a
daytime soap thing and no disrespect for
doctors but like I will I will agonize
over it and I will work so hard and I
will like go to the depths of the
character and whatever and not get it
don't get like I'll just read it oh
there we go I did not think about it so
I sent it off thinking I'd get a couple
of NPCs do you know what I mean I was
really like okay like that's it I'll
I'll do like a couple of kids probably
and maybe like some you know I don't I
don't know what but yeah I was not
expecting to get the lead one of the
lead roles so yeah you both mentioned
you know not really knowing what what
your role was going to be or how big the
game was going to be at what point did
you realize that Boulders Gate 3 was was
going to be a big deal like was there a
moment when you were like oh this is a
big thing that people are really going
to care
about I think I only just realized when
the game came out literally a month ago
two months ago whenever it came out
honestly like because I just had no
context of this why are you pissing
yourself laughing it's true I was GNA
say like maybe a year in a couple of
years in did you like
now because I knew it was like I I
enjoyed it and obviously I loved doing
it and everything but I I don't think I
ever had a a scope of how many people
loved it I just no idea honestly I just
didn't know I
think I think maybe to be fair I don't
think any of us expected this I don't
think anyone did like I didn't like no
um because we didn't know how well it
was going to be reviewed and um and
stuff like that like yeah the reviews
have been like have you ever seen
anything like it I haven't um but I
think I think I knew it was going to be
a big deal because
in in um Early Access like kind of
getting I started to get messages from
people and I was like oh this means a
lot to people this isn't just I am
entertained by this it's like I am
affected by this and I think that gave
me an inkling and especially like I
think I was lucky because I did go to
ComiCon um you couldn't de I think you
were no I was just had given birth
that's why yeah excuses you know women
lazy honestly honestly get it together
yeah like Whopper in you should be fine
whopping what a phrase Whopper in
Amazing Baby work right yeah I think so
yeah yeah whacker on your back off you
go so I think I think that like I think
Comic Con like and and properly meeting
people and going oh oh there's a face
here there's a person there's a soul and
they love they love this game and they
spent hours and hours and hours with it
sometimes like like fourth or fifth
playthrough and you're like okay yeah
it's it's an incredible thing about
video games that I feel like is unique
to the nature of the medium is that like
video games can be 100 hours long balers
Gate 3 can be 100 hours long if if you
think about 100 hours you have to spend
playing that video games can be by
people's sides for so many things like I
distinctly remember the game I was
playing when I went through my first
breakup this Grand Theft too 3 and I
know that because I was playing that
game for however many hours and being
like he sucked it was fine I know that
now but like there's so many life
experiences you can have that those
characters often reflect in little ways
that they're so therapeutic U to the
extent that there is a company that I'm
forgetting the name of uh unfortunately
um that is currently working to have
video games like officially considered
uh an accessory to therapy so you could
have a rating that would say this video
game is great for people with anxiety we
know that because it has this features
this video game is good for people with
depression like they're literally
working with the medical board to make
sure that video games can have ratings
that are also indicative of how they can
help with different mental health
problems and I just think that's like
amazing but also such a big part of the
kind of response that you get to a game
like baldis Gate 3 where characters are
going through ACH of emotional turmoil
together and it can reflect so many
things that happen in people's real
lives like you're helping people it's
such a cool thing like I don't know
about you de but like it's well actually
saying that I was
speaking I was speaking to someone um
recently who um was and I forgot to tell
you about this Dev who I mean mainly
because it was yesterday and we haven't
spoken today but um who was talking
about their autism and about how Lael
has really helped with that and it's the
same with Shadow so it's so cool like
people are help like it's people
discover parts of themselves and I think
that's because we were given so much
time and the writing is so beautiful and
deep and because of all these diverging
paths like allowing us to explore so
many different parts of of a particular
human oid in your case but you know what
I mean um like it's meant that people
can properly see themselves and as you
say like spending it's not just a film
it's not just an hour and a half passive
as well it's like you are doing it and
and I know with autism specifically
sorry I'm just like derailing because I
think this is so cool with autism
specifically uh it it really helps
people with facial recognition also in
part because they can slow down so like
you can process emotion you can process
facial expression you can process body
language and you're allowed to do it
slower because the TV show doesn't just
keep moving and there isn't a cut away
you can actually
are T ofes that are known in VR for
helping people with Autism social cues
better again I just think it's so
[__] cool it's such a cool part of
the industry Studio G yeah let's go
[__]
world uh how I had somebody comment on
one of my videos I can't remember
whether it was on social media or
something else but they were like thank
you so much for you have such an
expressive face and I'm like autistic
and it's really helping me to understand
like all your emotions this was not
necessarily to do with Boulders gate
because we didn't do facial capture but
it just made me think of your comment so
so yeah it it does it does help it's
definitely uh such a cool Avenue to help
even if it's unintentional which you
know is absolutely more of that um so
how much attention did you both pay to
reviews when they came out like did you
know review day was coming was it
something you were anticipating like
part of the dev team sitting there
waiting for the tens to come in I wasn't
planning on it but I think I think when
they kind of flooded in and they were
all really brilliant I couldn't help but
go
okay tell us nice things about the
project we've worked on um yeah and also
being on social media kind of like it's
unavoidable really isn't it true true
yeah I'm sure people on the group chat
weren't they as well de yes yeah we have
a group we have a borders gate group
chat very nice so um people kept posting
on there and and that was that was
really nice but I don't know I think a
few of us were quite nervous about it I
I don't think I was like nervous
necessarily because honestly I I even
though I had no context of how big the
game was I knew that it was good yeah I
knew that it was good I I didn't have a
doubt that it was going to be like
scores across the board and and it's
just wow I can't believe it honestly it
just because it's been so such a big
chunk of our lives and now to see it all
coming back and in such a positive way
is is really massively rewarding
actually it's almost definitely going to
win some Game of the Year Awards not to
jinx it but like I'm pretty much like I
would definitely think hope yeah well
just like I like if it does like like
even if it doesn't I'm like well
whatever we've achieved so much but if
it does it just reflects the the proper
passion of everyone involved like I
don't know it's just like there's
something just so special about it and
like even even reflected in like the
actors who just give so much of a [__]
about the audience and and and the
community and but also about laran like
they care so deeply about it so I'm like
if they do it would just be the most
perfect Karma because know your work is
good because you know that you all cared
and that all the people you're working
with is very talented so the public
stuff doesn't invalidate or validate
that it's just like a nice cherry on top
like if it does happen great if not you
still know you made something amazing
right like it doesn't take away from
that laran have such a a sense of humor
and and a and a and a Cool vibe uh
around this whole process and I I love
that I think they don't take themselves
too seriously while at the same time
putting everything into this
game and uh and they've given us so much
freedom to do whatever we want with the
characters pretty much um so it's
doesn't come across as pretentious like
a lot of effort a lot of care but it's
not it's not pretentious or the differ
being like a company that that takes the
work seriously but not themselves
seriously yeah and I think that's
absolutely it yeah and it's it's the
same with us as well like I think yeah
like the the actors like like I don't
know this why I love Dev so much as well
like she's so good at her job but is
also a goofy
goofball yes we all are we all have to
be yeah taking yourself seriously is
boring um how many like let's plays or
streams have you watched like have you
gotten involved in like watching people
react to certain
moments a bit not too like yeah I a lot
of it a lot i' start I've started
playing it myself with
my and um that's like however much I
watch bits it's not the same as as
actually playing it and that is like
that has made me appreciate it on such a
different level can't our house yeah
can't wait to have you around to our
flat Dev to play I think you would love
it oh my God I I can't wait I can't wait
I assume you've not played it then Dev
I've not played it and I found out the
other day or whenever it was that they
they've now got a patch where you can
play it on a Mac um and I have a Mac but
I feel like my Mac will die a very
painful death if I try and give it
Boulders Gate 3 so I don't know really
what to do about that but I'm desperate
to play I'm so desperate to play and I'm
not like a gamer at all but now seeing
everybody and seeing everyone's
reactions I'm like I really want to play
I want to do some battles and like
choices hard is it hard it is hard yeah
it's tough yeah yeah really why what's
so what's hard about it you can just get
you there's lots of buttons there are a
lot of buttons in this game but it's
more just that
like people enemies can kill you fast if
you don't think about what you're doing
it's
tactical you have to think about you
can't just sort of like click a button
like you can if I didn't play I played
it on um CU Al and I have started
streaming and if I didn't play it with
2,000 people shouting at me what to do I
would have I would like I was like
backseat game for me guys
please it's such a complex game again
it's it's incredible like the the game's
so complex that there are things that
you can miss without even knowing that
you've missed them which I think is part
of the appeal is that it's just you
never really know what's going to happen
I didn't know that there would be an
interaction where I would smear [__] on
my face in order to make some goblins
let me into a camp but here I am that's
a thing that I did in this
game and it's like you never really yes
you never really know what's going to
happen yeah yeah it's a lot uh but but
very very fun because you you're like I
wonder what will happen if I try this
and there's always an answer where a lot
of be like nothing happens that's it
yeah it's super creative and I've I've
heard obviously haven't played it but
I've heard that literally it's just a
game about thinking outside the box and
like picking up totally the last one
that I wanted to ask is like did you
have any like favorite scenes or like
standout moments for each of your
characters that you just like remember
with excess
fondness excess fond yes go on okay I'll
go first if you like yeah no I will but
but I'm not going to spoil it so I'm
just goingon to say the sunrise scene
because that's my favorite scene um yeah
Jen know is the one I mean
I
yeah think I don't know who directed
that scene because I'm confused I
thought it was Tilly but maybe it was
you I did some of your yeah it's been a
long years we did it it's been a long
four years and also we reshot quite a
few scenes so I think it might have been
both of you in different
iterations um but that scene is is one
of my
favorites it's beautiful it's a good
scene uh do I have a
favorite all of all of the romance
scenes I
love
um
no none nonone massive no there like
yeah like there's an end scene that I
absolutely adore
doing um is there a lot of awkwardness
in doing Romance when you're just like
in a booth yeah can't even imagine no
it's not really like you got to create
chemistry with yourself right yeah I I
was lucky because my girlfriend is my
director
so so that really really helped
genuinely and she would be my barometer
like I'd know if something landed
because she'd be blushing so you know
definitely helped
um yeah but no it it could be but you
could say the whole thing that's also a
valid answer if the whole thing is your
favorite thing then that's also totally
fine whole thing is my favorite thing
totally fine yeah uh it's obviously
there also bits of like random little
scenes that like come in like a side
quest or something like that like I'm
thinking specifically of like the circus
and things like that which are just um
hilarious they're hilarious little
asides here and there and yeah um yeah
so so those those are also great I think
the little moments just just as good as
the big moments yeah I think sometimes
like the little moments of Comedy which
would be in where we could be a bit
lighter like over big like you know like
emotional Arc or something and then you
just like redo a bit from act one where
it's like really light and you're like I
love that got to have fun
todaying yeah for sure no um game's
incredible you both did an incredible
job the whole cast did like it's I know
everyone's saying this to you already
I'm sure but it really is just such a
feed in video games I've been in this
industry for 10 years and there aren't
that there aren't a whole lot of games
that make me go how did they do this and
balers Gates 3 is one of them I'm so
fascinated and like so so impressed on
behalf of absolutely all of you but
we're done talking about balers Gate 3
enough it's over never again I love to
ask people this these final questions
here of just who are your favorite
actors who inspired you to get into
acting some of your favorite
performances doesn't have to be video
game related
obviously not to put you on the that's
that's a big question got so many I love
Violet Davis so much
um and I think my first my first like
and it funny I talked about this the
other day my first um like oh I want to
be you when I grow up was Emma Thompson
in Sense and Sensibility and much to do
about nothing um probably because she
was like you know older and blonder like
you know old and blonde older and blonde
and I just went like I could be you um
yeah she like I love I and then still to
this day like I will rewatch like Sense
and Sensibility very like English of me
like British of me but um uh yeah that
was like my first like inspiration I
suppose outside of Disney
films um yeah what about you
d uh yeah I I can't I don't know if I
can pinpoint hello I don't know if I can
pinpoint uh one particular Act
performance I mean I've always loved um
Angelina Jolie I've loved like in say
like girl interrupt like the early stuff
the raw stuff you know not NE the action
stuff girl interrupt is such a good film
um but you know just just seeing that
the even stuff like friends like I'm a
massive fan of friends and you know you
think like oh it's like hard to sitcom
but I know how hard it is to do comedy
for example and I think you know it to
make it look so easy and effortless is
is incredible and like growing up with
that and you just think like God yeah I
really want to do that I wonder if I
could do that um yeah I can't pinpoint
it to one specific performance but there
was just that sense of fun and play that
I really wanted to to tap into and and
luckily on lots of these projects like
Boulders Gate 3 you get to do that and
it doesn't feel like work feels like fun
directly off of that do either of you
have a dream role like something that
you would just absolutely to do or
someone you would love to
play no I think for me I I don't ever
want to do that because I feel like if I
it's it's kind of going back to the
whole um you invest too much and you
care too much about something and then
you end up like floundering because that
desperation is seeping through I think I
try not to idealize like certain roles
or like types of roles because
they're probably not the ones meant for
me do you know what I mean like whereas
if I kind of I don't I don't really care
where I end up as long as I keep going
and like then then stuff is like kind of
given to me that I would never expect so
like Shadow heart is totally not my
casting um like I don't I don't think
you would if I like if it wasn't a a
voice and mochat role I don't think I
would have played her just as probably
Debbie wouldn't have played a lizard
lady I don't know but um like I like
that that was that was chucked my way
and and I wasn't aiming for it do you
know what I mean whereas I think
definitely given me the the like the
experienced actor answer there which is
like you kind of can't really have those
dreams be again so much of your job is
rejection it's brutal every time I talk
to actus I'm like I can't even imagine I
guess if you Aspire for a specific thing
you're only setting yourself up to fa
you I guess the aspiration is like do my
best and enjoy my job rather than like
try to do this exact thing it makes
sense well yeah and also you don't know
what role you're going to get you could
get something like above and beyond your
expectations like with LEL and shadowart
yeah I yeah it was more than I could
ever have imagined from an acting point
of view and I honestly it blindsided me
because I never thought that that kind
of role would come from a video game
yeah yeah I never imagined that in my
wildest dreams I imagined something
completely different for myself and now
look what's happened how much more
amazing has it you know how much better
has it turned out yeah but you just
didn't see it coming but yeah when
you're fixated on like yes I want my
like a heavy dramatic role so I can win
my oscar like it doesn't necessarily
work like that really yourself alive in
this industry yeah and I mean
the like that's such a great game to
start in video games but now again
you've like opened a door to video game
acting in which there we have so many
good meaty performances like across the
board like it's I'm a big fan of my
industry it's all I'm trying to say um
and I feel like you can have a role you
didn't even know existed in a game you
didn't even know existed from a company
you didn't know existed like become the
the dream role just like retroactively
rather than some absolutely yeah and
that's kind of
awesome um that is all we have time for
today where can people find you what are
you up to uh is there anything you'd
like to give a shout out
to um you can find me on Twitter on
Instagram and on Tik Tok just search for
my name
um otherwise that's that's actually what
I have to say about that you'll find
plenty of content you'll find plenty of
content there I really don't need Tik
Tok is one of my favorite things in the
world so
noted hi
I praise indeed and you can find me on
in hang on what am I on Instagram Tik
Tok and I will start posting more on Tik
Tok and uh twitch as well and I think
I'm Jennifer J English on all of those
so I have to get uh Dev on one of the
streams so we can see how she feels
about balers Gear 3 playing it for the
first time that'd be fun it I promise
it's gonna
happen we've got it h have any anything
else that you'd like to share with
anybody before we
go we love borders Gate 3 we love B my
girlfriend is waving a big arm at me no
one online will believe a big arm twet
please can you say that was me that sent
the last tweet apparently there's I
don't know I something about Alana sent
the last tweet I don't know I'm so
confused I'm sorry about this I could
only hear bits of it and now I'm like
wait what is the secret message what
what is
this oh so um so so we we accidentally
went viral because um uh we on a on a
stream Aliana questioned whether my
girlfriend questioned whether um uh
Shadow heart was her favorite or whether
it was
laelle and and I we all know the answer
to that appropriately anyway apparently
she's just sent a tweet to say uh that
shadowart is in fact her favorite like
clarifying and now nobody believes her
so it's too defensive now sent it and I
would like to clarify that I did not
send it that shadow heart is her
favorite you have an Al by you are doing
this podcast time of recording you you
definitely didn't hold a gun to her
slightly off camera demanding that you
tweet that yeah I did not I did not hold
any
gun definitely didn't do that obviously
the answer is definitely didn't do that
obviously obviously well I'm glad you uh
you could fix that um Good Luck
there uh thank you both so much for
joining me I'll leave links in the
description to where people can find you
both and happy Boulders gates for
everybody thanks happy bers gate three
yay thanks for having us yeah bye by bye
[Music]
bye
that